you
I'm just going to start off with a very
serious take and reinforcement learning
actually maybe before I even do that let
me just start with a very quick informal
poll how many people are using
reinforcement learning in their work
like I think I see one how many people
have ever read a book on reinforcement
learning or in fun okay so I feel a few
people okay so that was kind of my
expectation and this talk you'll see is
it's mostly very introductory so
hopefully you can walk away from this
with some sense and please what the
topic is
I have a lot of code that's available
for you to look at afterwards but let me
just start off with this very serious
take on the topic what is it figure
eight incredible it's five four five
you can't see these camera no you're not
cheating area no I swear that just
coming to me
okay versus yes
I'm licensed you only have 75 more to go
what's this one there's a couple wavy
lines sorry this isn't your lucky day
give a little pair of this and volunteer
didn't you we're paying you aren't we
yeah I think we have to give him the
electric shocks what are you trying to
prove here anyway I'm studying the
effect of negative reinforcement on ESP
ability the effect I'll tell you what
the effect is it's pissing me off
well then maybe my theory is correct
okay take the five blocks ahead I will
mr. so many of you are probably familiar
with that scene from ghostbusters it's
actually based on somewhat of a real
experiment so and it brings up this this
question of negative reinforcement and
it's directly related to a lot of what
we're going to talk about so just to
start with the talk here is called in
search of pi PI and reinforcement
learning and many fields is a policy
that you're trying to learn and that's
the focus of what we're going to be
looking for we want to learn how to
follow the policy to go from one state
to another based on a set of actions
this idea of reinforcement learning is
very very old you can really find it all
the way back I've just included two
codes here to give some sense of that
John Locke had a ideas
Ripple's philosophy wherein there's some
superpower that gives rewards and
punishes and based on that people will
kind of follow certain kinds of behavior
and in Alan Turing's famous essay where
he introduced the Turing test and he
also introduced this idea and talked
about the total number of rewards and
punishments applied and and that also is
getting a crucial aspect for
reinforcement learning because we're
trying to get at an expectation of
reward
over time so this is a very old idea
it's kind of coming into popularity
again now so this is the outline I'm
going to start off by putting
reinforcement learning in some context
against things that people are probably
already seen little look at some
motivating examples for how it's being
used we're going to go through the very
simplest example which is an armed
bandit and little plug for John miles
White has a book on that is also from
this Meetup
then we're going to look at different
models of reinforcement learning
problems um we'll go through different
methods for solving those models I'll
walk through some open source code
that's available for doing this and then
I'll get some references so you can dig
into a little deeper okay so starting
off with some context so just first of
all you know the show of hands in here
is not overly surprising this is from a
recent post and machine learning
subreddit and I said why is
reinforcement learning so barrier and
many of the comments were pretty
derogatory but my basic take on this is
that I think reinforcement learning is
kind of underappreciated within our
community the purpose of it is that
optimize over some long term behavior
and that's something he isn't doesn't
easily fall out of other kinds of models
it's good for handling complex
environments and also it provides a
framework for working with streaming
data which is becoming increasingly
important and we recently had a talk on
that topic machine learning as a field
is usually kind of separated into these
three different categories and my guess
is that people are very familiar with
the first two
so in supervised learning you have
examples of gear they're labeled and
you're trying to fit a model from a set
of features to figure out what what
those labels are in unsupervised
learning
you have unlabeled data and you're
trying to find if there's some kind of
pattern to it reinforcement learning is
some time
as being kind of like supervised
learning you're given a a set of states
and actions and from there you're going
to try to learn some function but
hopefully you know you'll see as we go
along it's actually fairly different so
there are different kinds of views of
how these things relate and I think it
it basic level they are actually quite
different a slightly more nuanced view
would say that they're actually fairly
strongly related there are ways in which
each of these different branches of
machine learning are used so I've kind
of put at the center this idea of active
learning and that's really where you get
all three different forms of machine
learning coming together whatever if
anyone has ever used active learning but
it's also an interesting field so there
are you know clear relationships between
these things and there's also another
view which is even more complicated but
which basically looks at the complexity
of the problem and and in this view you
have supervised learning kind of at the
bottom left corner it's it doesn't have
any kind of sequential nature to it it
also doesn't have any kind of reward
structure but as you add those features
in you get more complex problems in the
top quadrant you have Biscay multi-armed
bandit s-- which again maybe some of
yours from other words and there you
have a reward structure but you don't
have any kind of sequential nature to it
and then as you add in the sequential
aspect you get two reinforcement
learning and there are actually theories
that allow you to go from reinforcement
learning down to supervised learning by
using what are known as reductions so
again there are a lot of it intimate
relationships between these different
methods so what is reinforcement
learning disorder with I just mentioned
there's a really fantastic book it's
called reinforcement learning as by two
researchers in the field Richard Sutton
and Andrew Barton
Barto and I highly recommend this book
it's also available for free online so
definitely take a look at that a lot of
what I talk about is you know
take it from here and some way so one
idea that they introduced the very
beginning is a this idea of a system
that wants something again we're kind of
getting into this idea of getting
rewards we're trying to achieve a goal
so as at a basic level a reinforcement
learning problem you have an agent
that's taking actions in an environment
and that environment may have some kind
of uncertainty in it and it's going to
receive rewards as feedback from the
environment if the goal is to find a
policy that will take your state and
give you an action and you want to find
the policy that will maximize your
rewards over time and it's very tightly
related to ideas from psychology and
animal learning assembly after questions
any point please Center up I'll be for
this to be interactive um that's a great
question so the question was is the
environment stable there are kind of
different ways of thinking about that as
with everything there's nuance and there
are ways of thinking about the
environment as as changing over time as
well most of what I'm going to be
talking about will be there's
uncertainty in the environment but it's
stable so this is kind of a model for
how the problem is structured so there's
an agent and that agent takes actions
against some environment and the raw
environment that gives feedback in terms
of an updated state of reward so we're
always going to be kind of following
this model as I mentioned this is used
in a lot of different areas most
popularly I would say within artificial
intelligence particularly robotics it's
very popular there and I'll walk through
some examples of robotics where it's
being used control theory and optimal
control I don't know if anyone here is
involved in that area but sequential
decision theory and there's also this
idea which I listed at the bottom
approximate dynamic programming
approximate dynamic programming is
basically another word for reinforcement
learning
they're kind of what we found over time
is that this exact set of ideas has
sprung up in different fields at the
same time and that's great because it
shows how powerfully these ideas are but
it also is led to a problem with
different notations which I'll comment
on as well and then with the
neuroscience reinforcement learning
ideas have been very powerful at
explaining how dopamine operated
operates on the brain and so that's a
big active area research and in
psychology as well how people learn
based on interacting weather environment
there's been a lot of study in that area
and again if you look this was a survey
done by by Casbah sub sorry and when you
can see he did a survey of how often
reinforcement learning shows up in
papers and it actually is occurring
around a lot of different fields so you
know it you know a lot of places where
you see these applications are in AI and
robotics but it turns out that it's
really being use very broadly if you if
you think about it in a broad way just
from an AI perspective I'm sure many of
you have seen this textbook some most
popular textbook for AI and if you look
at kind of where reinforcement learning
fits within the field of AI if you just
take this is kind of the classic
approach they work through kind of
search algorithms at the beginning of
their textbook basically and so in
search algorithms you're thinking about
I have a state-space so I'm going to
search out through throughout that
entire space and as I get more and more
complex problems they get to this topic
of sequential decisions we're going to
talk about the ideas in sequential
decisions which include MDP which is
Markov decision process and it also gets
at a game theory and then later on
several chapters later they get into the
topic of reinforcement learning so the
difference between reinforcement
learning and sequential decisions if
anyone's seen the sequential decisions
before is really that reinforcement
learning
has even less structure to it it has
less of a model of the environment than
a typical kind of operations research or
sequential decision setting these are
some of the kind of major considerations
and areas where people are doing
research right now so and you know some
of this kind of applies broadly to all
different areas of learning but
generalization is a big problem in
reinforcement learning
with a lot of reinforcement learning
they end up running into the curse of
dimensionality it's a huge issue
because you're trying to basically
search through a huge state space of all
these states and actions and you need to
figure out how can you find the optimal
behavior but then you're running up
against this problem if I'm searching
through all this state space I have to
shrink that state space down and then if
I get into a different setting that I've
never seen before how can I generalize
from that so that's a big area research
and that's where people are combining
ideas of supervised learning with
reinforcement learn I'll comment on that
sequential decisions
is kind of unique to this topic so here
we've got a model of the environment and
now we want to know okay given this
model of the environment how am I going
to act and that's where we get into this
planning problem related to that is this
idea of exploration versus exploitation
and I mentioned this multi-armed bandit
problem which I'll go through a little
more detail but the issue is if you're
searching through this space and you're
learning different ways of acting and
you're getting rewards and as you
continue to do that there's some cost to
searching so I want point to you say
okay I've searched enough I have a good
policy and I should start to exploit
that so there's this tug-of-war between
how much do I continue to search and how
much do I start to act and then another
big area again these are very high
dimensional problems so convergence
given these big state spaces on these
algorithms how can we actually confirm
that we've reached the optimal point and
these are essentially very complex
problems so
there are a lot of cutting-edge research
now that's trying to prove that certain
kinds of algorithms converge and there's
been a lot of success recently within
the last few years on that lot this
comment briefly on the kinds of
different flavors of this problem so
they vary in terms of the kinds of
uncertainty for instance am i able to
know what state I'm in or not can I know
what action to expect or not whether
there are multiple people involved so
you know one classic setting for
reinforcement learning is in game
playing and in there you may have two
people who are playing and their
adversarial so you have to think about
if I act a certain way how is that
person in there and that gets into these
multi decision-maker problems there are
two very different ways of formulating
the problem either as model-based or
model free I'll go through that as well
right now people are really more focused
on the model-based version of that which
seems kind of counterintuitive you know
I think within supervised learning we
like to think of model free learning is
being fantastic because you're not
imposing your your structure on the
problem but model based learning also
has a lot of benefits particularly it's
able to learn much more quickly and then
again you know basically the complexity
of the problem is the state space
discrete or as if an infinite is a
continuous-time or discrete-time and so
forth and as we make our problem more
and more complex you know the approach
to solving it becomes more and more
complex so all these decisions are very
important when you characterize a
problem I mentioned Richard Sutton in
many ways he's kind of the father of the
field and he recently gave a talk trying
to characterize what are the main ideas
for my career for learning and he chose
these four so I'm just going to comment
on them quickly and then well you know
I'm going to go through more detailed
examples of each but the first one he
thought about was that there's a time as
to it and many supervised learning
problems we could just kind of throw
time out of the equation right we just
say given a certain set of features or
States what do I expect here we're
actually thinking about things taking
place over some period of the life of an
of an agent so the time aspect of it is
very important potentially somewhat
unique to this the second one he listed
was reward or value and here I think one
important idea behind this is that we're
thinking about things in a very
long-term way so when you come up with a
supervised learning model you're saying
I'm sitting here in this current
situation I have this set of features
that are you know such in such a way it
tells me to do this thing in this
setting we may not always follow that
because doing things that a supervised
learning setting is very greedy so she
always thinking what's the optimal thing
to do right now but what we really want
to think about is what I do in the long
run and that's where this idea of value
I want to think about things over some
long period of time samplings is very
important that has helped to deal with
the problem of dimensionality so in
classical kind of AI search problems
you've got this big state space and
you're basically searching with the
whole thing that's kind of the very
basic idea found but if one of the key
ideas kind of leading in a reinforcement
learning was let's use Monte Carlo
methods so rather than searching the
entire state space I'm going to go down
one track now and I'll try another one
that I'm going to sample over the whole
space and that's led to a lot of kind of
improvements and convergence and then
bootstrapping is the idea that basically
I've got an estimate of value right now
and I'm going to update my belief of
that value based on what happens next
so you're using your existing knowledge
of the world and continue to improve
your updates and again then that helps
in both in terms of kind of improving
convergence but also in terms of getting
better estimates
okay so let me just quickly go through a
few examples of how this is being used
so kind of thinking of the classic
example is the Skinner box I'm sure many
many of you are familiar going to this
but the psychological experiment from
the 20s and it was really foundational
in terms of psychology they were looking
at rats who were touching levers and
they would get rewards under certain
settings and they were able to kind of
model how did the ring
the rats respond to reward and then
again here there's this tight
relationship between psychology research
reinforcement learning and I recently
noticed is actually kind of an idea this
takes off but it's kind of a human
version of this now so there's a device
you can buy called a padlock and it
literally will shock you if you don't
behave well so you know I could see
maybe Apple watch version two well we'll
have this feature as well but you know
it's a powerful idea
another very classic example and again
this is really getting at a dynamic
programming but dynamic programming many
of you may be familiar with that that's
really foundational in terms of
reinforced unlearning so there's the
Traveling Salesman program problem is
probably one of the most well known
computer science problems and the nine
excuse me
dynamic programming from Richard bellman
was able to solve it more efficiently
the other algorithms prior so it was a
really big leap forward in terms of
solving shortest paths kind of problems
so it's again very foundational for
computer science probably the most
well-known reinforcement learning
problem comes from games so there was
this problem it was called TD gammon and
a researcher at IBM fit a model using
ideas called temporal difference
learning which I'm going to go through
and he fit
using a neural network so again you get
this kind of intimate relationship
between reinforcement learning ideas and
supervised learning you're combining a
model from supervised learning with this
kind of behavior over time that's where
you get a lot of power and he was able
to beat all of the world's grandmasters
using this Bergen so it was a huge leap
forward in terms of computers and games
when this came out and you know a lot of
people look at this particular problem
where he was playing backgammon and
they've they've studied it and I said
you know this is kind of the epitome of
reinforcement learning we're not going
to go to her from here there hasn't been
a lot of coverage I would say of the
topic since this in particular there
wasn't much success in games like chess
it wasn't you know particularly another
game that's very popular this game
called go and I don't know how many of
you play this but it's a very
complicated game a lot of thinking that
go would never be solved by a computer
it's a very complex game so and go you
have an enormous number of states so in
terms of this kind of curse of
dimensionality problem it's very very
difficult now this is kind of getting
into this idea of having what's called
function approximation so again you're
combining ideas from supervised learning
the ideas from reinforcement learning
and by doing this they've made recent
major breakthroughs in the field of of
go so you know when they started
introducing this sampling approach to
the game you can see initially they were
looking primarily this blue line is kind
of classic search problems these are
classic AI search algorithms to solve
the game of go and then they started
looking at using a sample based approach
and ever since they started taking that
approach the y-axis here shows a measure
of how successful the game player is and
they actually started to beat the world
grandmasters at this level prior that
they were kind of anyone in this room
could have beaten them they're very
simple programs so again kind of getting
into this idea of function approximate
and in this case this is using gradient
descent methods but that's made major
leap forwards in this field in the last
few years and then just one that's very
quick example many of you may be
familiar with this as well but this is
no idea what to do prior to
you shoulda left
she lies women
got booze to be areas
you're doing
Oh
so that's again another very well-known
popular example okay so let me just go
briefly into what I would call the
simplest example which is the
multi-armed bandit so many of you again
may be familiar with a multi-armed
bandit a John Laws Wade has written a
book about it
and in terms of reinforcement learning
you can think of that as being a
reinforcement learning problem with one
state mostly what we're thinking about
here are sequential decisions I've got
multiple states I'm acting over some
sequence of events in this problem you
only have one state so in the
multi-armed bandit problem you know I'm
a one-armed bandit is basically a slot
machine you can think of it that way and
you have say a set a number of slot
machines you could pick from so you can
let's say you walk into a casino you
don't know which one is going to pay off
you have this row of slot machines you
want to figure out which one is going to
pay off the most so this gives you set
of routines you can follow to pick to
pick a machine basically so you have a
set of actions you can take and in this
case those actions would be machine
one-arm sheet 2 long etc and you can
choose which one you want to pick the
pick every time you pull on that slot
machine it may pay off or it may not
there's some probability distribution to
that and then over time there's this
idea again of value so we're not just
interested in did this machine pay off
right now we're interested in overtime
how much did it pay so this you know
many people will probably be familiar
with this xkcd comic which is really
directly related to this problem so you
can think of against someone walking in
and pulling on that lever in this case
they're very dire consequences right
it's not that they didn't just win the
the sly machine so most people when
they're in this circumstance they take
that negative feedback and they would
probably quit right but
so what would a normal person do they'd
say don't do that again but of course
you know the scientist wants to know is
that really what's going to happen every
time so they keep doing um so you can
think of our reinforced learning about
in the same way if you just simply took
that negative feedback and never pull
that lever again then you wouldn't learn
right so we have to keep experimenting
and that gets into this exploration
versus exploitation trade on so I'll
just briefly describe the most basic
version of this which is called epsilon
greedy and there are many many other
versions of this there are issues with
this one but it's simple to explain so
let's say you have some idea you keep
testing these different slot machines
and you figure out okay you know this
one paid off that would be your best arm
so you don't have some notion of what's
your best arm right now that's your
belief of the maximum value if I keep
pulling that one but periodically you'll
go and you'll say okay you know what
it's time to go test the other ones so
there's this parameter epsilon and you
can set that to be any number you want
let's say you set it to be point one
which for whatever reason a popular
choice and I would say ten percent of
the time I'm going to go out and
randomly test all the other machines and
then the rest of the time I'm going to
go use the machine that I think is the
best by having this kind of policy you
end up being able to converge on the
best machine and this is kind of a
popular mechanism for website
optimization so again some of you may be
in this field but you want to know if I
put you know a certain ad on certain
page will people click on it and you
know will I get that reward so you want
to be able to typically people think
about a/b test this is kind of an
extension of that so that gets into
again this exploration versus
exploitation trade-off how can I be sure
that I'm going to explore as much as I
need to come up with the optimal
solution okay so let me just go through
some models
and I'm going to focus on a problem
called a Markov decision process but
I'll try to put it in some context yes
in principle we choose epsilon I'm sorry
in there like a way to choose like an
optimal value epsilon yeah there is an I
mean again I don't know how many people
even use epsilon greedy now there are
other methods like upper confidence
bound and Bayesian methods I think are
more popular and another thing I think
most people would do like a decreasing
epsilon for instance you wouldn't
necessary set a value to just keep stick
to that but you would overtime migrate
yeah so just to start with I want to put
this again a little bit of context so
many of you will be familiar with
bayesian networks as a way of kind of
explaining a probabilistic model so in a
Bayesian network we would typically have
States there's another form of network
which extends this that has two
additional notes a decision node which
is like an action and a utility node
which is a reward and there I'm just
going to stick to Markov models here but
many people will have looked at Markov
chains before this is a very popular
time series model in Markov chains we
assume that all the states we see are
observable and also that we have no
control over transitions so they happen
with some probability you go from one
state to another so we can kind of
extend this idea down further Markov
decision process whether we're going to
mostly focus on the states are
observable meaning if I'm a robot I know
where I'm located and I have control
over what I'm doing so I can turn right
I can turn left and so forth and I know
what I'm doing in the kind of time
series since a hidden Markov model
extends the Markov chain by saying that
the states that we're in are not
observable and so that becomes a
powerful idea and and in the
reinforcement learning setting you can
have the same idea which is called a pom
DP which is for a partially observable
our Markov decision process and again as
you make these things more complex the
solution methods become much more
complex so most people have tended to
focus on Markov decision processes even
though pom dps are very popular now and
in part because if you think about
certain kinds of problems like robots
for instance how do robots know where
they're located they have sensors and
those sensor readings are always noisy
and not only are they noisy but to get a
good reading you need a more expensive
sensor so if you can model things in as
kind of unknown States and learn from it
in that way you can actually not only
make problems more easy to deal with but
you can also make them more easy to
implement so Markov processes the Markov
property itself which again is important
to all of this is just that the
probability of the next state is only
dependent on the prior state or then I'm
sorry the existing state so it doesn't
matter all of the information that came
before a given state transition all the
matters is where I am right now
and this pretty third topic is also you
could go through a lot of detail on like
for instance how do you define a state
you can define States in very complex
ways that would include prior
information for instance right so the
whole subject of defining the state is
in and of itself a very complicated
question but this is the simple idea
just that we're only going to sit in
order to know what happens next all we
need to know is where we are right now
okay so the Markov decision process as
these two additional features right I
mean I'm in a state I can take an action
and when I take that action I receive a
reward and then I transition to the next
day so that's going to kind of fully
define the reinforcement learning
problem hidden Markov models have also
become quite popular in the past few
years and in this case there's a hidden
state
so you don't know what the state is you
just know some observation of that state
and then you need to learn try to figure
out what the state is based on the
observations you have so you basically
have a belief of what that state is and
then partially observable Markov
decision processes which are the
extension of Markov decision processes
introduce the same idea so rather than
knowing what state I'm in I see some
observation and then I have a belief of
what state I'm in so again you've got
this kind of extension to the problem
okay so let's define that the
reinforcement learning problem X was
something that and the reinforcement
learning problem we have to set up dates
and those things could be continuous or
discrete in most cases people try to
either have discrete states I will try
to discus eyes the states because if
they're continuous then it makes the
problem eventually significantly more
challenging you also the set of actions
that you can take so again you could
think about maybe I'm a robot
I can go north I can go west east so
forth and again typically that scene is
discrete but it could be continuous and
then you have some reward that you get
for being in a state so I move into a
certain state and I get a reward that
reward could be zero and that's actually
a very important idea as well and in
addition that we have some probability
distribution given a state an action
that I'm going to transition into the
next state and a lot of people also
introduced a discounting factor because
they don't want to have to keep learning
forever basically this discounting
factor will give more or less weight to
the most recent observations and the
objective really that we're looking for
here is to find a policy and the policy
is just some function that says given
that I'm in a given state again that
seat could be any complicated thing it
could be in the sky is blue and I'm
outside and I have my umbrella my hat or
whatever it is it could be any different
set of features and given I'm in this
state what actually should I take so how
are we going to learn what
policy is that we should take so the way
we're going to do that is I'm going from
one state to another and every time I
transition from one state into another
I'm going to receive a reward and
overtime I'm going to build up this idea
of value and operations research they
refer to it as utility but really what
we're looking for is what's the
expectation of reward for being a given
state and the way we end up implementing
this is using something called
development equation so virtually all
reinforcement learning problems are put
in the same way that the value of being
an estate and following a certain policy
is that I get a reward for being in that
state and then I get from there every
subsequent reward so um that here you're
getting kind of a very powerful idea I'm
breaking off what's happening right now
versus what's going to happen in the
future
and this part of it here is kind of an
estimate right and another thing that I
just want to highlight here is that this
is for a given policy so I get any given
policy could be optimal or not but you
can still kind of dictate what's the
value of following a certain policy and
overtime when we know values for every
policy then we can kind of start to say
what's the optimal one um another
important equation that I'm just going
to here is this Q function so rather
than simply talking about what's the
value of being in this current state we
can talk about what's the value being in
this state and taking an action and the
difference between these two equations
may not be all that readily apparent I
mean it's really just the introduction
of this a and why would we really care
about that well it turns out that
reformulating the problem in terms is Q
function allows us to solve things
without having any knowledge of this
function or this function and that's
really where we could ever reinforcement
learning versus kind of traditional
operations research and dynamic
programming and incidentally the
difference between the Q
and the V is this a but if you take the
maximal accuse overall the nays then you
get the sim the value function is
literally just the maximum all the
values is you could get for taking an
action given a state okay so let's just
kind of think about through this problem
a little bit and we'll see kind of how
things fall out and there is a canonical
example that most people use which is
called grid world here I'm just showing
a maze but you can think let's say I'm
starting a given position and I want to
get to a certain goal how can I
formulate this problem now I have no
feedback to start with about what's the
right direction to go given a current
position so I need to start kind of
introducing some feedback in a liquid
you might do that in different ways one
way would be to say when I reach the
goal state I'm going to get a big reward
um another way to form that department
would be when I'm not in the goal state
I'm going to get a punishment
okay so again we're kind of getting into
this pavlok thing right I'm going to get
shocked every time I'm not in the goal
so let's think about that okay if you
were in this any given state and every
time you're in a state you get a
negative one reward say and then over
time you can kind of think about how
that's going to work it's going to sum
up to some value so let's say I'm in
this state to get from here out to here
if I'm collecting negative one rewards
on each step I'm going to end up with
this value and now if you just kind of
take a look at this which is just
literally summing up these rewards at
each point and this is our value
function then you can easily just kind
of look at it and say okay if I'm in
this state here which would be the best
way to go okay I mean based on these
values this number is less negative all
right so this would be the way to go and
you can continue that process and that's
how we go from having a sense of value
I'm in a given state and I have a
certain value from it to a policy so if
we will learn this value function then
we can go from there to having a policy
and a policy literally that says I'm in
a given position I have a certain value
expectations so I'm going to take a
certain action I mentioned earlier that
one of the key ideas behind
reinforcement learning versus under
traditional operations research a
dynamic programming is that a
reinforcement learning we don't have the
full model of the environment and what I
mean by that is if I'm in a given state
and I'm going to move into another state
I don't know
first of all initially what reward I'm
going again and second of all I don't
know what the probability of me moving
into that state is so what we're saying
there is a reinforcement learning
problem I don't know what this function
is and I don't know what this function
is and so there were kind of two
approaches to this problem one approach
says let me learn what those functions
are and the other approach says who
cares what those functions are let me
just find out what the best policy is
and I'll go through how this two
approaches work and as an aside I
mentioned earlier this has kind of grown
up in different fields against some of
you maybe from operations research in
operations research there's just a
different notation not only is there a
different notation but actually they
think about it in kind of the negative
way so in reinforcement learning you
know we're very positive people and we
have a positive value function in
operations research they're very
negative people and so their cost to go
function J is literally just the
negative of this so they're trying to
minimize a cost but we're trying to
maximize our utility
okay so let me just go through we've
kind of defined what this problem is
right we have this set up we have action
states or rewards and we have
transitions and now the question is how
can I learn how to how to do this so I'm
just going to go through what the kind
of major ways of solving these problems
are and then I'll briefly go through
some of the software that exists for
demo so I mentioned this a little bit
earlier but this picture for Michael
Lippmann and Michael Lippmann by the way
just as the site is offering a
reinforcement learning class through
Udacity so some of you may have seen
this if you're looking to kind of dig
into this a little further he has a
course on Udacity which is quite good
and it goes into a lot more detail on
game theory that I'm going to cover so
it's also interesting in that sense but
there are kind of three fairly distinct
approaches to how to solve these
problems what we're trying to learn here
is this policy so I'm in a state and I
want to know what action today and this
is really what we want to learn there
are methods that simply just try to
learn that okay so forget about all of
these issues of value transition
probability and so forth let me just try
different paths and search over the path
space basically so there are some
approaches that are very direct they
just trying to learn this thing directly
and they these are called policy search
there are other methods that I'm mostly
going to focus on which try to learn
even a state and an action what's the
value and once you know the value you
can go from the value to learning what
the what the policy is so it's slightly
less direct at getting one while we're
trying to what we really want but then
there's the other extreme which says
rather than trying to learn a value to
learn a policy let me learn this
transition probability and let me learn
the reward function and then this is
kind of interesting and this is where a
lot of research is being done now this
is called model-based reinforcement
learning and this is kind of like a
supervised learning problem I have these
different pairs of data and learning
these functions so this is very indirect
in this case we're learning about the
environment itself so we're learning how
the environment operates and we're
learning that in order to
what the value is and then to dictate
what the policy is and there are
benefits for all of these methods and
they're being used in different ways for
instance policy search requires less
memory it's a little more direct
so some robotics are using those methods
model based learning I can do a lot of
simulating so basically you're learning
about the environment and then you can
do kind of Monte Carlo simulation over
and over and over again and you can
improve your updates based on the
simulation so this approach is able to
converge much more quickly but may not
be as easy to implement as this so in
order to describe these different
methods and use get another diagram so
this is called a back up diagram now
when reinforcement learning this idea
backing up information from the future
is very very important so just the way
this back up diagram works is you get a
picture of how the method for solving
the problem operates you're in a given
state and you're taking a given action
and that's going to move you know in
another state and given that other state
you're also receiving a reward at the
same time and so this particular picture
that I put up here corresponds to
dynamic programming in dynamic
programming you are stepping forward one
step typically and you're also you're
trying every combination basically out
of actions and States so you're doing a
full look up every time and again this
this is an idea that's been around since
the 50s and it requires a lot more
information so dynamic programming many
of you may have either seen or heard
about there are two basic methods for
solving it the first is that I'm going
to miss just value iteration and that
was introduced by Richard bellman and
when he introduced this whole problem to
begin with in terms of dynamic
programming one issue to do with the
hemic programming is that you need to
know what this is and you need to know
what this is so again you will see
dynamic programming another fee
it's kind of less applicable in
reinforcement learning because typically
we're thinking about issues where we
don't know those functions the other
method is called policy iteration and
that was introduced in the 1960 and
these methods are slightly different the
policy iteration one I just want to kind
of drill into a little bit further
there's this idea of generalized policy
iteration and this idea is kind of used
throughout all reinforcement learning we
can generalize the problem in this way
right basically what we want to do is
evaluate to learn this optimal value
function and then we want to use our
updates of values to improve our policy
and there's this feedback between the
two so you know I've kind of gone
through this a little bit already but
what we've kind of separated this
problem and to learning a value function
and then updating a policy and then that
gets into this idea generalized policy
duration that you see over and over
again again even in all these different
methods so the next kind of method that
came up was using Monte Carlo and this
is fairly different than dynamic
programming in this case we're sampling
from the state space and every time we
sample we're going to go all the way to
some terminal state and by doing that
over and over and over again we can kind
of learn about the environment but
you'll see um what's different about
this diagram than this one in this case
we're going through all the states one
level in this case we're only going
through one policy so we're going to go
all the way to the end
following one path we're going to learn
about it following on that this is kind
of one of the key ideas in reinforced
learning is called temporal difference
learning and this was introduced really
kind of formalized in the 80s but some
of you particularly from an AI
background may be familiar with Samuels
paper where he looked at checkers and in
the 40s so this idea has been around
again for a very long time and basically
what the idea and temporal difference
learning is this back up diagram you'll
see the difference seen this one this
one is really only going forward one
step and every time we do that we're
looking at what changed basically so if
we look at this equation I've got some
expectation of value I'm going to update
that given my existing expectation of
value plus some additional thing and um
oh sorry yes so this alpha is called the
learning rate so given what the next
reward is plus what changed that's how
I'm going to update my expectation about
you and this is a very powerful idea
just looking forward one step and kind
of looking at how my expectation has
changed so this of what changed yeah I
got again I mean these things are very
probabilistic all right so when I
transition from one state to the next
the reward you see it received may be
different where you end up may be
different and so I have some expectation
of what they're so there's that aspect
there's also the aspect that you haven't
searched the whole state space right so
what's my expectation if we go back this
earlier example let's say we've gone
through this thing one time and again
there's this probabilistic aspect if I'm
only looking forward one step and I'm in
this state and let's say I'm receiving
negative one reward every time then my
expectation of what the value of this
state is is only going to be based on
this one transition right so here you're
kind of walking forward in space but
you're only learning from one step at a
time and what about the next time I
revisit this state let's say you know I
continue in this process I'm going from
one state to another I'm learning what's
happening every time over time there's
this backup process that happens so
eventually let's say I reach the goal
one maybe when you recycle you receive
some reward
well that reward is going to slowly kind
of propagate its way back
you step through you've got some
expectation of value in each state and
then as you go on to the next one that
value from the goal state is going to
work its way back and eventually you'll
converge on what the real value that
state is so does that answer your
question
so what's changing over time is really
not the value of that state per se in
this problem but really our
understanding what the value with so all
these V's here we know could have had
sort of them being pretty like in a
probabilistic sight these are our
estimates of value and and you're
updating your estimate as you walk
through space and sample the state space
so we're running pretty long a time and
I just want to get through a few more
things I just an incidentally this
presentation is hopefully fairly
comprehensive and I will be making
available afterwards obviously so you
know and if you have questions on your
point
don't hesitate to reach out to me there
are really two temporal difference
learning methods that are very very
popular I just want to touch on kind of
what the difference between them is so Q
learning is one and key learning as soon
as a model free method this was you know
from the late 80s and what that means is
that in Q learning you separate the
policy you're going to follow from the
issue of discovering your your value I
mentioned earlier this there's a
separate formulation of value and Q Q is
the value for being in a state and
taking an action and we're able to learn
that function much more easily and one
reason why Q learning is very important
necessarily I said it was people were
able to show convergence and relatively
quickly and the reason they were able to
do that was because of this model free
aspect of that it separated the value
learning part from the policy sarsa is
another popular method and in this case
the policy learning part of it is
integrated into
the value learning part so you're
learning a policy and value at the same
time and when you do that you end up
with different kinds of behavior for
instance in a given robotic kind of
problem let's say your robot is walking
along a cliff and some said the robot
tends to be very conservative it will
say as far away from the cliff as
possible in Pew learning because it's
independently learning the policy and
the value it tends to be more aggressive
basically if you just kind of formulate
these problems similarly and it will run
walk right next to the cliff so you know
again which method you choose kind of
somewhat depends on the scale scope of
your problem and then the last kind of
key idea is this idea of backing up by
estimates and this gets into a notion
called eligibility traces so the
temporal difference algorithm that I
just showed you a minute ago I was
looking forward one step
well what if we and then if you go over
to Monte Carlo that's looking forward
all the way to the end right but in
actual fact we kind of parameterize this
to go anywhere in between and it turns
out that if we do that we go any number
of steps we can both speed up the
problem we can also get more accurate
results so I'm just this picture here as
an example lambda is this number of
steps that we're going to take and when
I mentioned earlier that example of TD
gammon where they learned backgammon
that was an exact example of this they
were looking forward multiple steps and
it turns out that if you set this lambda
value to something other than zero zero
being ahead of a classical TD's case and
not one either one would give you fully
Monte Carlo but if you parameterize this
somewhere in between you end up be able
to get a better model out of it so
combining all these ideas together it's
very powerful and also it kind of
unifies the field so this is something
that people have been kind of looking at
recently which is just taking these
ideas of eligible
tres is being able to go multiple steps
at a time what's still sampling gives
you very powerful models and so you have
kind of these different methods that
I've described dynamic programming is
kind of the most you know widely used
like a simplest form of it you have
temporal difference learning and the
difference between these two you can see
is kind of how far you going to search
on each step and on the other hand you
have this idea of how many steps am I
going to go and that's where you get
into this lambda parameter and there you
go from kind of a classic AI search
problem all the way down to Monte Carlo
and so you have the space of approaches
and they kind of get unified by having
this bootstrapping parameter lambda okay
yes yeah yeah that would definitely be
up here kind of in this region and then
that by the way is a very popular method
still as well but I mean I'm sure this
kind of depends on the problem the
benefit of one of the key benefits of
the idea is we're talking about here is
first of all it's samples it doesn't try
to search throughout the whole space and
then it also has this idea of
bootstrapping so you know kind of going
back to the very beginning not only are
you going to be searching throughout
space but every time you search start
space I'm going to update my current
belief of my state based on my prior
basically so it's almost like a Bayesian
idea okay so let me just briefly touch
on kind of code that you can use to work
on these problems and then I'll I'll
open up for questions okay so what I
think one of the key reasons why there
were a few hands in here at the very
beginning is because it's very hard to
do reinforcement learning and one aspect
from them is that it's not available
really in any widely used data analysis
software so and and most of the time
when people want to do
first learning problem they kind of
tailor the problem or they tailor the
solution explicitly to the problem and
we all know from doing supervised
learning that when you introduce your
domain knowledge into the problem you
almost always get a better solution
right just having black box algorithms
never works as well as having some prior
knowledge to be able to at least
structure your features and so forth so
you know it's not overly surprising that
you should need to structure these
things but um you know in the current
state of affairs reinforcement learning
problems tend to be hard to implement so
I've listed a number of kind of the most
complete pieces of software for this and
I just really want to dig mostly into
this first one so RL glue is a library
that came out a few years ago and the
idea is to abstract away the language so
RL glue is a server that sits in between
different language interfaces and a
large portion of the reinforcement
learning community is not using this um
you know it's on another side there's a
pseudo annual competition it hasn't
happened it doesn't happen over year but
it does happen some years where they use
RL glue and so there's one actually just
starting so hopefully you'll all kind of
run out after this meeting and go into
this competition and you know it has
some very interesting problems including
I mean as a simulator directly rid of
that helicopter problem that I was
talking about before
and so what's amazing on some is that
with RL glue you don't need to worry
about what language you're working in so
I could write an environment like a
helicopter simulator and you could write
an agent that would try to optimize that
helicopter
so RL glue is this the server that just
communicates through networks typically
write an interactive mission
I guess always on the same machine there
was some discussion of a one point about
doing it kind of over the Internet and
we're not doing that yet but it provides
a very clean structure to the
reinforcement learning problem so we
have an agent that kind of will take
those rewards and state updates and it
will try to learn what the policy is you
have an environment that's giving all
that feedback and then you have an
experiment program that's kind of
dictating what's happening over time so
our little glue has language interfaces
for C C++ Lisp Java MATLAB and Python
and I I'm pleased to announce that I
created an aura package for it too and
I'm going to work on a Julia one next so
what I would really love would be for
there to be more of a community built
around RL glue and one of the really
beautiful things about as I mentioned
before is that there are already a lot
of environments written for it in other
languages and so if you're not
interested in writing a helicopter
simulator many of you may not be but you
may be interested in kind of
experimenting it with as a toy problem
and you can do that right now so you
know I mentioned this is still you know
fairly early stages I haven't posted it
to cry yet but I have implemented an
interface for it so you know you can
play with that and I'll post some
updates on my blog or on Twitter you
know some examples using it on top of
that I'm also working on our package
that's going to implement a lot of the
algorithms that I've talked about and
more than that I'd also like to really
make it implement a lot of kind of
cutting-edge methods so I mentioned this
eligibility traces some of these methods
are really cutting-edge people are using
these kind of all kinds of different
fields so some part of this is already
implemented this is already implemented
and and the TD lambda I should say and
it's just on top of RL glue so I've
given these different methods for
solving problems you can interface lots
of different of our
and it also has different methods for
solving coming up with a policy I think
we're pretty tight on time at this point
um and yeah this is basically you know
how you would implement a model using
this new art package and I will send
around code examples after to talk so
just to wrap up some kind of further
things for you to dig into if you know
any of this is piqued your interest I
mentioned you know the code for this
talk is available on here actually I may
not have pushed it but I don't do that
when I get home but it will be available
here if it's not there right now
RL glue the the art package is also on
there in terms of the community there's
a Google group that has a lot of kind of
the key members of the community are on
there there's this RL community site and
I mentioned this competition earlier so
that's taking place here are some kind
of survey literature that if you're not
looking to read you know this whole book
but you are looking for 20 pages then
you could pick up some of these if
you're looking for a more general
overview Russell and Norvig is
unfortunately very very expensive but
fantastic so I recommend it
probabilistic robotics is also a
fantastic book and this book here
unfortunately put the title but I'll put
it before I center room is available for
free online and is also a fantastic
resource and has reinforcement learning
in it and incidentally I didn't include
this in here but if you're looking for
machine learning books that talk about
reinforcement learning there are a
couple there as well including I think
Tom Mitchell's book excuse me as it has
a really nice concise chapter on it so
some of you I may have read that book
before you might want to
visited in terms of reinforcement
learning books these are kind of the two
classic references and it's really
fantastic but sudden and bardot have
released their book for free on their
website so definitely go on there you
can download it and this is also another
book I want to set in this colleagues on
algorithms that that's also very good
and it's also free these are some of the
key people in the field again this will
be in a presentation and that's the
whole thing so apologies I hope I didn't
put too many people to sleep here but
down you know hopefully we have a couple
of minutes for any questions and if not
I will be going out for beers afterwards
all tough to get to check with something
I need any questions how do you define
the stick
all these techniques is because in some
cases when today or if your definition
of state doesn't doesn't comport with
the alley
all right I'm talking about
physical plant right like your model is
not the plant and there are there are
certain things how many areas and things
are not in it yeah
is there any is there any way feeling
funny this state definition is there
anyway what can you deal with cause I do
I introduce a kind of fuzziness and okay
so the question was it can be difficult
to define States and let's suppose that
your state definition is either a
unknown maybe you don't you don't know
your state at all or maybe you have some
belief around your state so yeah there
are absolutely ways to go about that you
know as I mentioned the less you know
about the environment the heart of the
problem and the algorithms you have to
use are harder but the palm DPD that
whole series of literature directly
relates to there's some uncertainty in
your state so in that scenario you
basically have a belief about your state
so we're again this is really kind of a
Bayesian idea there's some probabilistic
distribution of what state you're in and
again you can define your state however
you want but given that belief every
time you make an observation you're
going to kind of update that belief so
it definitely allows for uncertainty in
the problem I don't have did that answer
question yeah yes a concrete example
maybe your own work or some other work
of what kind of problem is solved and
specifically speak about what is a state
how the state defines how do you figure
out the value is how you define value
and what actions your agency take so
although concrete over certain if you
can yeah and so I will give you an
example from my work period I guess
there's a famous paper by Michael
Carranza I don't know how many of you
are familiar with him he's deep and he's
written a lot of important literature in
this topic but also in other areas and
he wrote a paper in 2005 they looked at
what some is the optimal execution
problem so this is kind of directly with
Ada finance and again this is used in
finance in some areas but it's basically
it's useful in any case when you've got
some sequence of decisions you have to
make and there's uncertainty right and
you have a goal so the optimal execution
problem in finance is very well-defined
you're given a certain number of shares
of some stock to trade say so you're
sitting as a trader and someone says or
execute ten thousand shares of Apple
today and your objective is to get the
best price possible so in the Michael
Kern's paper they set it up so that the
state is it again you know it's an
interesting paper to look at because he
gets into this state definition question
he could define the state as both you
know how many shares dialects to left to
execute what does the order book so for
anyone is not familiar with with trading
and where different markets there's an
order book that says there are certain
number of people who are willing to sell
shares at a certain price certain number
of people are willing to buy shares at a
certain price given how the order book
looks right now given how many shares I
have left the trade and you know he
includes other variables that might be
consider kind of more predictive and his
actions would be at a given point in
time I'm going to sell some percentage
of the shares or buy some percentage of
issuers hard for the problems formulated
and the way he approaches the problem is
he again this has a lot to do with you
want to search throughout the state
space in some way so he creates a
simulator of the market so he has market
data that he's replaying and he replays
it base
exchange rules that say if I'm going to
buy a certain number of shares this is
what's going to happen to the order book
and so forth so he simulates what would
happen based on taking certain actions
or given points in time based on for
certain states where a state is how much
time I have left and so forth and he's
able to come up with optimal policies
and he's able to compare that against
and in his predict or paper he didn't
kind of compare it against well
established benchmarks I guess
unfortunately but he compared against
another kind of simple algorithm it
showed that by introducing additional
variables he was able to get much better
policies and so forth so that's that's
an example from from finance but I mean
you can see for instance it's being used
very widely in robotics and so I don't
know exactly how Google cars are working
but you know if I had to take a guess
this is heavily involved because what
you're trying to do and as I understand
them the Google car problem is basically
you have some model of the world and
they have it the way they are training
their cars is not based on you know like
one way to do self-driving cars is to
have one car to communicate with another
so I'm approaching a car I can see that
car
it's it's you know be giving me lots of
feedback and I can kind of dictate how I
should behave another way to do it would
be to have some map of the world
basically with an immense detail and
then come up with these kinds of
policies to say given current state and
so forth so there's clearly a lot of
training that goes into that kind of
problem and I presumably using some
methods that are extensions actually
related this and you know there are
certainly indications of that Google
recently acquired a company called deep
mind that some of you may have seen and
then deep minds kind of big public
things that and you know include a
reference to this also they they
published a paper about learning Atari
games and it was all about reinforced
learning again so a lot of these game
problems where you have no prior
expectation of like given you know a
current state on you know I'm Mario and
in front of a pipe which I do you just
kind of basically by trial-and-error you
go through the state space in you
so the question was is there some kind
of topology to the state space basically
so I don't have to go through every
state so I kind of mentioned this a
little bit but you know the big problem
in reinforced one big problem I should
say is generalization and the problem is
you have all these states and actions
and you have this huge person to mention
oddity problems so how can I possibly
visit every state or in a reaction in
fact in q-learning the convergence proof
required that you visit every state and
every action infinitely often ok so I
don't know how many of us have time for
that so you know a lot of the research
that's gone into this recently is trying
to generalize and that gets into really
using supervised learning methods to
build a model of the environment and in
that case you basically yeah you do end
up with you know you're fitting up model
like a functional form to your state
space so you're trying to learn what
model actually projects out this big
space that way if you know if I visited
this state and I visited that state but
I never visited this one I could
generalize because I have a model of it
I don't know if that answer your
question
sorry beautiful so the question was can
you apply it to a mature online poker
and I don't have any direct experience
in that but but there are actually
papers on poker using reinforcement
learning and in fact they are
interesting as well because they are
looking at game theory
so in poker you've got a multi-layered
problem and so you know I get my kids
and I could include some references
there I don't know how many people would
actually apply these methods in online
poker but I imagine more than one yep
one them any less Chris
Kwasi look like a bunch of features
action
so the question was well as a policy it
looked like so in the classic methods
that I kind of mostly showed here
they're they're basically tables so you
do a table lookup you're in a state and
that table tells you to take a certain
action and then again in this kind of
generalization a world we don't we can't
do that because you know if a robot has
some wind all of a sudden it's in a
state that it never simulated now it's
going to fall off a cliff so instead we
will basically you know like one very
popular area is just literally linear
function approximation so you can run a
regression yep essentially saying give
it certain sets of now use expectations
what's my model of what action I should
take so you can come up with a policy as
a function instead okay I think you know
if there any more questions so you know
happy to take them either over email on
Twitter or over beer and you know thank
you everyone hopefully you know we'll go
out and choose good policies from here
on